[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la rivalité
croissante entre les etats-unis et la
chine menacent de sanctions reproche
accusations mutuelles l' escalade ne
fait que s'accélérer alors quelle est la
réelle ampleur de cette confrontation
donald trump lance une offensive
diplomatique contre la chine sur tous
les fronts coronavirus hong kong peuple
des ouïghours à majorité musulmane
sunnite habitant la région autonome du
xinjiang une série de nouvelles
sanctions est même annoncée côté
américain pékin promet de riposter
donald trump lui menacent de rompre tout
lien avec la chine refuse de parler à
jean ping par ailleurs le gouvernement
chinois devient aussi la cible des
candidats à la présidentielle américaine
par exemple
joe biden promet de créer une coalition
composée d' allié américain pour contrer
l'influencé de pékin à l'international
les états unis lancent le réseau de
prospérité économique
une nouvelle force économique régional
censé renverser la domination indice
très le chinoise par la relocalisation
de sa production vers les pays membres
en quête de soutiens washington invite
aussi l'inde l'australie la corée du sud
et la russie au sommet du g7
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les liens entre les deux
superpuissances économiques les états
unis et la chine
c'est le blitz tout d'abord washington
et pékin ont de très intenses échanges
commerciaux près de 20% doute toutes les
exportations chinoises sont destinés aux
états unis washington les produits
chinois représente un cinquième de
toutes les importations et lorsque les
importations en provenance de la chine
ont fortement baissé l'année dernière la
croissance chinoise a ralenti à 6,1 pour
cent un taux record aux etats unis les
effets négatifs se sont aussi fait
sentir
il s'agit avant tout de la hausse des
prix avec comme conséquence une baisse
de la consommation
plus de 1500 entreprises américaines ont
une présence sur le sol chinois y
compris de vrais géants commerciaux
comme apple google hp août et cela
malgré les effets néfastes de la guerre
commerciale et de la crise sanitaire
plus de 70% des entreprises américaines
envisagent pas de relocaliser leur
production hors de la chine
la raison en est la forte dépendance
vis-à-vis des fournisseurs chinois et de
la main d'oeuvre relativement peu cher
interconnecté commercialement les deux
pays dépende aussi l'un de l'autre sur
le plan financier
deuxième plus grand créancier étranger
du gouvernement américain pékin détient
à ce jour des obligations américaines
pour 1100 milliards de dollars une dette
colossale qui d'un côté assurent la
stabilité du yuan mais de l'autre mais
en position fragile la valeur du dollar
car la vente des obligations américaines
risquent de déclencher une chute
importante de la devise américaine
et cela à son tour un traînerait une
dévaluation de la monnaie chinoise
la pandémie de kobe de 19 à aggraver les
tensions déjà existantes entre pékin et
washington donald trump accuse la chine
d'avoir dissimulé la gravité de
l'épidémie à son début selon pékin ces
accusations le serbe qui a détourné
l'attention des américains dans leurs
problèmes internes
pourtant la crise sanitaire n'est qu'un
des terrains d'affrontement entre la
chine et les états unis
parallèlement le président américain met
la pression sur pékin au sujet de
hong kong en cause la nouvelle loi
chinoise renforçant le contrôle de pékin
sur cette région spéciale enfin un volet
de sanctions est annoncée au sujet des
ouïghours une minorité ethnique que
washington qualifie de victimes des
répressions chinoise
cette escalade inédite de tension
entraîne une lutte diplomatique acharné
à l'international en quête de soutiens
donald trump invite l'inde l'australie
la corée du sud et la russie au sommet
du g7 la chine quand elle durcit le ton
à l'égard de washington et de ses alliés
et promet une entente riposte contre les
actions américaines alors jusqu'où
pourrait aller ce bras de fer le récent
accord commercial pourra-t-il tenir face
à cet échange de courtoisie enfin
comment la rivalité sino-américaine
influence-t-elle la course électorale
aux etats-unis pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons michel fouquin
conseiller scientifique au cepii
monsieur fou qu'un bonjour bonjour tout
d'abord pourquoi c'est l'administration
trump qui cherchent à réviser les
relations américaines avec la chine
pouvoir tout d'abord que barack obama en
fait avait déjà commencé à réviser ses
relations avec la chine en essayant de
créer une zone de libre échange avec un
certain nombre de pays d'asie tout en
excluant la chine donc barack obama
était consciente que la chine
représentait un défi un challenge qu'on
peut dire pour les états unis et qu'il
fallait donc trouver des alliés pour
essayer de contenir la montée en
puissance de la chine
trump lorsqu'il arrive il est obsédé par
les déséquilibres commerciaux alors
guézy ce déséquilibre de la balance
commerciale qui effectivement sont de
plusieurs centaines de milliards de
dollars chaque année et on peut penser
que c'est trop et donc son objectif
principal lorsqu'ils arrivent c'est deux
établir la balance des paiements des
états unis il va s'attaquer à la chine
il va s'attaquer à l'europe
il va s'attaquer au japon un certain
nombre de pays va mettre la pression en
imposant des tarifs douaniers aux uns et
aux autres
ce qui va changer je dirais c'est qu'on
s'aperçoit que la chine n'a pas du tout
l'intention de suivre un chemin vers une
plus grande démocratie mais qu'au
contraire c'est un pays qui devient
disons plus autoritaire et qui s'affirme
comme un chat comme un commun ne serait
un nouvelle superpuissance mondiale et
en tant que telle n'a pas du tout
l'intention de suivre les la voix
américaine et donc on voit à travers
notamment le projet des routes de la
soie qui vise à connecter la chine avec
tous les continents du monde
on voit aussi avec le programme made in
china 2025
la chine à l'intention de devenir une
puissance économique technologique
avancé et donc d'un certain point de vue
elle met en en question le leadership
technologique américain donc voilà un
certain nombre de raisons qui font que
depuis que trump est arrivé il ne cesse
de durcir son langage à l'égard de pékin
alors d'un autre côté il espérait avoir
obtenu quelque chose c'est ce qu'on
appelait l'accord de faith one fait swan
c'est l'accord par lequel la chine
s'engage sur deux ans accroître ses
importations de produits américains de
200 milliards de dollars je y sommes un
en particulier des produits alimentaires
alors ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on s'aperçoit que tu fais de
notamment de la crise du colis de 29
c'est que ce probablement ça va être
très difficile sinon impossible à la
chine d'acheter autant de produits
américains dans les deux années à venir
aujourd'hui
certains experts disent que le monde est
en quelque sorte au seuil d'une nouvelle
guerre froide
est-ce que vous pensez que cela pourrait
être vrai et si oui quelles sont les
différences entre la guerre froide avec
la guerre froide entre l'urss et les
états unis si on parle des relations
entre les etats-unis et la chine
aujourd'hui
oui il faut bien voir que employé des
termes comme guerre froide
c'est bien pour les titres des journaux
pour attirer l'attention des lecteurs
dans la réalité il faut bien voir que le
bloc soviétique c'était tout de même une
époque où le monde qui est quasiment
coupée en deux il y avait peu de
relation entre le bloc soviétique et les
économies occidentales y en avait mais
disons qu'elle était très réduite
aujourd'hui on est on est dans une
situation complètement différente
le la des premiers détenteurs de bons du
trésor américains c'est la chine juste
d'ailleurs japon si vous regardez les
échanges commerciaux de la chine avec
l'ensemble des pays développés ces
gigantesques alors que l'union
soviétique ne ne vais jamais atteint un
tel niveau
donc il ya une interpénétration
aujourd'hui des économies qui fait que
d'une certaine façon aux personnes fois
personne n'a intérêt à a cassé à casser
le système
j'ajouterai peut-être à ça l'idée que
finalement
tout le monde profite à l'heure actuelle
de cette de cette situation et donc les
entreprises américaines notamment n'ont
pas envie non plus de se couper de la
chine il faut il faut se souvenir
simplement que par exemple general
motors fabrique plus de voitures en
chine qu'il n'en fabrique aux etats unis
aujourd'hui
même chose pour fox wagen même chose
pour d'autres grands constructeurs
toyota donc la terre l'intégration de
l'économie chinoise dans l'économie
mondiale est telle que on va faire
attention avant de casser la baraque à
une journée vraiment une situation
extrêmement grave et condamnable a alors
les points d'inquiétude
en fait les six si on veut c'est d'une
part que la chine n'arrive pas à
constituer un bloc
elle a de mauvaises relations avec ses
voisins avec le vietnam avec la corée
avec le japon bon donc pour eux la chine
est véritablement une menace en termes
de sécurité nationale est donc la
différence de l'union soviétique il y
avait tout de même un certain nombre
d'alliés peut-être plus ou moins
volontaire l'europe de l'est notamment
la chine elle n'a pas véritablement
d'alliés forts là elle a des clients
elle a des gens qui lui sont redevables
de son aide financière mais assez peu
d'amis au total ça c'est une grande
différence de l'époque celui merci
beaucoup monsieur fou car nous allons
poursuivre notre analyse tout de suite
mais nous vous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question merci nombreuses accusations
pressions économiques et diplomatiques
donald trump mène une intense offensive
contre la chine le 20 mai et pointent de
nouveau pékin du doigt au sujet du coc
vie 19
c'est la compétence de la chine et rien
d'autre qui a provoqué cette tuerie à
l'échelle mondiale accusant la chine
d'avoir tardé à alerter le monde sur
l'épidémie est d'en avoir dissimulé
l'ampleur
le président américain envisage une
série de mesures en représailles le 27
avril
trump évoque la possibilité de demander
à pékin de payer des réparations pour
les dommages causés par l'épidémie la
facture pourrait se chiffrer en
milliards de dollars selon le chef de
l'état
quelques jours plus tard
l'administration américaine dit ne pas
exclure des taxes punitives contre l'
empire du milieu
un appel à des sanctions est également
lancée depuis la chambre des
représentants où un projet de loi est
introduit le 14 mai s'il a adopté la loi
projetée permettrait au président
américain de sanctionner nombre de hauts
responsables chinois
et pendant que l'examen du projet se
poursuit donald trump prend fin mais la
décision historique de couper les ponts
avec l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qu'il accuse de complaisance envers
pékin à son tour techint démentent toute
tentative d' influence sur le ms selon
la diplomatie chinoise les accusations
de trump ne serve qui a détourné
l'attention de ses propres erreurs les
etats unis continuent de blâmer sans
fondement la chine et l' oms pour
détourner l'attention de la population
américaine et dissimuler la réalité de
leurs réponses inefficace à la pandémie
car en ce qui concerne le kobe 19 les
etats-unis enregistrent à ce jour le
plus grand nombre de cas au monde à
savoir plus de 3,5 millions chaque jour
les médecins américains enregistrent des
milliers de nouvelles infections
le nombre de morts lui vient récemment
de franchir la barre des 140 milles à la
crise du comique 19 vient récemment
s'ajouter une autre source de tension
entre les deux pays
la situation autour de hong kong en mai
2020 le président américain accuse la
chine de viol et l'autonomie de cette
région administrative spéciale
en effet la loi sur la sécurité
nationale
adopté par pékin est composé de cet
article elle autorise notamment pékin à
réprimer toute action qui menacent la
sécurité nationale comme le séparatisme
ou la subversion en vertu de cette
nouvelle loi les organes chinois de
justice et de police n'ont plus besoin
de demander l'autorisation du
gouvernement local pour intervenir sur
le territoire de hong kong est pour
washington cet acte constitue une grave
violation de l'autonomie de cette région
administrative spéciale en réponse le 29
mai donald trump annonce un volet de
sanctions
parmi elles la révocation du statut
spécial dont hong kong
en pratique cela mettrait fin aux droits
de douane avantageux dont bénéficié ce
territoire en commerçant avec les états
unis
autre mesure sensibles pour pékin
l'annulation des visas pour les
étudiants et chercheurs chinois ayant
des liens avec l'armée chinoise
la mesure concernerait au moins 3000
personnes
et pendant que pékin travaille sur une
contre offensive washington lance une
autre offensive diplomatique visant
cette fois la politique chinoise à
l'égard des musulmans ouïghours
majoritaire dans la province de xinjiang
au nord-ouest de la chine selon
l'administration américaine la chine
il détient illégalement plus d'un
million de personnes dans des camps
d'internement où d'endoctrinement le 22
mai 2001 le département américain du
commerce annonce avoir pris des
sanctions commerciales à l'encontre de
neuf entités chinoises supposément
impliqués dans les violations des droits
humains de la communauté ouïghoure
concrètement l'administration trump leur
impose des restrictions aux importations
des technologies américaines
l'autre volet de sanctions vient d'être
signée le 17 juin 2020 il prévoit des
sanctions contre un certain nombre
fonctionnaire chinois est supposé être
responsables de la répression des
ouïghours
de son côté le gouvernement chinois
dément l'existence des camps de
détention selon lui il ne s'agit que de
centres de formation professionnelle
destinés à aider la population musulmane
apprendre le chinois et à trouver un
emploi ainsi pékin à son tour accusé les
états unis de politiser la question
musulmane
en chine les questions liées aussi niang
ne concerne pas les droits de l'homme
l'ethnie ou la religion mais la lutte
contre le terrorisme et le séparatisme
nous exhortons les états unis à cesser
d'utiliser les questions liées aux tic
niang pour s'immiscer dans les affaires
intérieures de la chine
pour donald trump la situation est
pourtant inverse
ils accusent la chine de vouloir
s'ingérer dans les affaires internes
américaine
son but serait d'empêcher à tout prix
l'élection du candidat républicain aux
futures présidentielles américaines
la chine elle dément toute tentative
d'ingérence pourtant les deux candidats
à la présidentielle américaine adopte
chaque un ton intransigeant envers la
chine en mai 2020 donald trump va
jusqu'à vouloir rompre toute relation
avec pékin pour cent en incapacité
présumée à empêcher la propagation du
coc u19 joe biden lui le candidat
démocrate n'est pas moins critique à
l'égard de pékin
en cas de victoire il promet de monter
une coalition internationale afin de
contrer l'influencé chinoise
la pression américaine s'accentue mais
jusqu'où ira-t-elle compte tenu de la
forte interdépendance économique entre
les deux pays
quels sont les risques qui planent sur
la récente trêve commercial comment les
deux puissances géopolitique
s'affrontent hôtel à l'international la
réponse après la pause
[Musique]
les relations sino américaines
traversent une période difficile
donald trump évoque même la possibilité
d'une rupture totale entre pékin et
washington
la diplomatie chinoise elle se dit prête
à une nouvelle guerre froide leurs
relations n'ont pas été aussi dégradée
depuis déjà très longtemps
en 1972 le président américain richard
nixon effectué une visite officielle
historique en chine une première depuis
l'instauration du gouvernement
communiste nixon signer alors avec mao
le communiqué de shanghai et proclame
l'adoption par l'amérique de la
politique d'une seule chine les etats
unis reconnaissent donc la république
populaire de chine comme l'unique au
gouvernement légitime chinois et taïwan
comme une province séparatiste sous sa
souveraineté
des relations diplomatiques partiel sont
alors établi elles deviendront complète
en janvier 1979 la république populaire
de chine commence certes à jouir d'une
reconnaissance universelle mieux payés
fragilisé économiquement résultat de
longues années d'isolement sur la scène
internationale
dès la fin des années soixante dix la
république populaire de chine lance des
réformes afin de moderniser l'économie
du pays et instaure un socialisme de
marché
pékin veut attirer les capitaux
étrangers et profite de la main d'oeuvre
abondante et peu cher pour faire de la
chine un pays à tenir
résultat le pays multiplie les accords
commerciaux et son taux de croissance
mais cesse d'augmenter les etats unis
ils jouent un rôle prépondérant et
deviennent en 1979 le troisième
partenaire commercial du pays
l'initiative des états unis la
république populaire de chine intègre le
fmi et la banque mondiale en 1981 et
liens commerciaux avec les états unis
continuent de se renforcer tout au long
des années 80 après la chute de l'urss
une nouvelle phase s'ouvre dans les
relations de pékin et washington
continuant son rapide développement
économique la chine veut s'affirmer
davantage sur le devant de la scène
internationale et parler avec la
superpuissance américaine d'égal à égal
les deux parties deviennent méfiante
face à leurs intérêts divergents et
navigue entre crise et compromis à la
fin des années 90 les relations sino
américaines sont minés par des incidents
diplomatiques ponctuelles telles que le
bombardement involontaire de l'ambassade
de chine à belgrade lors de la guerre en
yougoslavie en 1999 où la collision
entre deux appareils des forces armées
chinoises américaine au dessus de l'île
de man en 2000
malgré ces accros les liens commerciaux
continuent pourtant 200 ans cistre les
entreprises américaines fleurissent en
république populaire de chine qui
poursuit l'industrialisation de masse
son importance croissante pour
l'économie mondiale lui ouvre la voie
vers l'intégration à l'om c'est en 2001
en échange la chine s'engage à baisser
les tarifs douaniers et de libéraliser
son régime économique en renonçant par
exemple à certaines politiques de
contrôle par l'état
pour les etats-unis cela représente une
opportunité pour les entreprises de son
pays ou
ra plus de marcher l'économie chinoise
quant à elle continue de croître
devenant la deuxième puissance mondiale
économique en 2010 juste derrière les
etats unis pourtant les relations
commerciales sino américaines deviennent
de plus en plus déséquilibrés à partir
de 2012
la chine exporte considérablement plus
aux etats-unis qu'elles n'importent de
produits américains
et la tendance ne fait que se renforcer
le déficit commercial des etats unis
vers la chine dépasse 374 milliards de
dollars en 2010 est dix fois plus que 20
ans plus tôt alors que ses prédécesseurs
ne se sont pas attaqués à ce problème
donald trump s'en prend dé a prise de
pouvoir à ce qu'il voit comme le déclin
industriel américain dès 2018 rampe
impose de nouvelles taxes draconiennes
allant jusqu'à 50% sur plusieurs
milliers de projets chinois la chine
répond par la réciproque
alors que la guerre commerciale aura
coûté 35 milliards de dollars en deux
ans les deux pays se mettent d'accord en
janvier 2020 aube il dit ce qui semble
laisser place à une certaine période
d'accalmie ce pragmatisme mutuelle
n'empêche pourtant pas une autre
offensive économique de trump sur la
chine
au niveau international la chine produit
environ un tiers de tous les biens de la
planète c'est usine du monde produit des
biens stratégiques dont dépendent
beaucoup trop de pays selon
l'administration tram pour essayer de
renverser cette tendance
elle lance le réseau de prospérité
économique composé des états unis de
l'australie de l'inde du japon de la
nouvelle-zélande de la corée du sud du
vietnam et peut-être d'autres encore son
principal objectif est de briser la
domination indus
les chinoises pour détourner sa
production vers les pays membres le
groupe n'est pas encore créée
officiellement mais les destinations
prioritaires sont déjà choisis c'est le
vietnam et l'inde à la main d'oeuvre bon
marché occupant une position stratégique
ce combat contre la superpuissance
commerciale chinoise pour le président
américain passe aussi par la volonté de
soustraire à pékin les entreprises
américaines et briser leur dépendance
des taxes accablante sont introduites en
au début de la guerre commerciale donald
trump demande directement les dirigeants
des multinationales américaines de
quitter la chine résultat plus de 50
entreprises dans apple google ou
microsoft travaille déjà sur le
transfert de leur production vers l'inde
le vietnam ou encore la thaïlande
la tendance se généralise avec la
pandémie ducobu 19 selon les médias
locaux il pourrait y avoir jusqu'à mille
entreprises qui réfléchirai à quitter le
pays parmi lesquelles il y aurait des
centaines de sociétés européennes
aujourd'hui des pays entiers lance de
généreux programmes pour stimuler la
relocalisation des entreprises en dehors
de la chine
c'est le cas par exemple du japon et de
la corée du sud ces deux pays sont
invités avec l'inde dans le réseau de
prospérité économique la nouvelle
alliance conçu par donald trump le
président américain at-il trouvé une
association idéale pour isoler la chine
dans sa propre région
tout n'est pas si simple puisque tokyo
et séoul sont très proches de pékin
leurs économies sont étroitement liés
ainsi il sera très difficile de les
convaincre de rompre complètement ces
liens l'inde pourtant amis américains et
adversaires chinois elle non plus ne
semble pas être prête à tourner
complètement le dos à pékin exemple des
escarmouches entre les militaires
indiens et chinois sur leur frontière
disputée en mai et en juin washington
saisi l'occasion et se propose en
médiateur mais new delhi rejette sa main
tendue
préférant négocier seul en quête
d'alliés donald trump passe donc au plus
haut niveau le club des principales
puissances mondiales g7 ou serait ce
plutôt le g
11 puisque le président américain hôte
du sommet g7 en septembre de cette année
a décidé d'y inviter quatre pays en plus
c'est d'abord l'inde l'australie et la
corée du sud trois états influents
certes mais aussi essentiel pour la
stratégie anti chinoises de donald trump
et en cherchant encore plus d'alliés
potentiels
il inclut la russie dans cette nouvelle
liste d'invités car si jamais moscou
allié et ami de pékin s'éloigner de la
chine
ce serait évidemment un autre atout dans
la manche de trump la chine croit que
toutes les organisations et conférences
internationales doit favoriser la
confiance entre les pays et promouvoir
le multilatéralisme
toute tentative d'en faire un petit
cercle anti chinois est vouée à l'échec
et donc pékin a de quoi s'inquiéter car
au fur et à mesure que l'épidémie
progresse l'europe ne voit plus pékin
d'un oeil si amical dans cette
confrontation lieu n'est pas neutre nous
partageons un système politique avec les
états unis et ne voulons pas passer au
système politique chinois
en mélangeant le soft power et la
communication agressive la chine at-elle
saper ses propres perspectives
at elle des ressources pour résister à
l'offensive économique américaine pour
mieux comprendre si le monde est
vraiment au bord d'une nouvelle guerre
froide nous rejoignons à nouveau michel
fouquin conseiller scientifique au cepii
monsieur fouquin les états unis selon
vous réussiront ils à créer ce front uni
avec leurs alliés contre la chine alors
bon effectivement vous avez deux alliés
trois alliés qui sont qui sont qui
dépendent de la défense militaire
américaine ça s'appelle le japon ça
s'appelle la corée du sud
ça s'appelle taiwan la c3 la jarrie dans
une certaine mesure ils n'ont pas
d'autre choix que d'être
sur la ligne américain je n'exagère
peut-être un peu mais je pense que c'est
tout à fait correct ce sont essentiels
pour les autres le vietnam vous savez
qu'il ya une longue tradition de
confrontation avec le vietnam ça me
paraît difficile avec la ddt
vous avez entendu parler des incidents
sur la frontières himalayennes
là les choses se menacent de tourner mal
sur le plan de l'indonésie peut-être
peut-être le pays qui aurait le plus de
modhac reçu avec la chier parce qu'elle
est plus loin déjà il n'y a pas de
différends territoriaux avec avec la
fidh donc on peut voir des pays comme
l'indonésie rester proche de la fidh
autrement dans la région l'australie la
nouvelle arme enfin surtout l'australie
sera sur les positions américaines
ça c'est clair voilà en gros on peut
dire est que la russie doit elle faire
dans une telle situation selon vous
prendre parti ou essayer de trouver une
position neutre la russie alliée de la
chine
vous avez bien vu que la russie a fait
le choix de la chine
sinon explicitement du moins dans les
faits dans les différentes vote aux
nations unies on voit en général que
chine et russie sont à peu près sur les
mêmes positions sur les mêmes votes
c'est donc sur le plan stratégique je
crois que c'est clair que la russie et
la chine son alliée c'est peut-être un
terme un peu fort mais sont sur des
positions communes ont des intérêts
communs ont des intérêts communs qui ce
qui consiste à remettre en question le
leadership américain qui est qui et
pesant pour eux pesant pour la russie
depuis les incidents qui ont eu lieu en
fin plus que les incidents qui ont eu
lieu avec la crimée avec l'ukraine
donc les états unis ont pris des
sanctions malgré l'offre irait contre la
russie les européens aussi donc voilà
ccl
la russie n'est pas neutre à l'heure
actuelle dans le conflit etats unis
chine ici par la force des choses ils
sont plutôt sur sur la ligne chinoise
merci beaucoup
michel fouquin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle vous êtes
conseiller scientifique au cepii
merci encore d'avoir participé à cette
émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]